Good morning, today we have a very important
and relevant question coming up with Sukkos Sukkos
where we have Yom Tov Sheni Yom Tov
Sheni. If we have somebody who is from
Chutz La'aretz Chutz La'aretz visiting Israel, so in
Israel we keep one day of Yom Tov
Yom Tov and in Chutz La'aretz Chutz La'aretz
there are two days of Yom Tov Yom
Tov and somebody who is going to be
returning to Chutz La'aretz Chutz La'aretz that his
da'aso lachzor da'aso lachzor, he is currently of
the view that he is going to go
back to Chutz La'aretz Chutz La'aretz, so the
majority of poskim poskim are of the view
that he keeps Yom Tov Sheni Yom Tov
Sheni even in Eretz Yisrael Eretz Yisrael. So
our question is, can the person who is
a Chutznik Chutznik who is going to be
returning to Chutz La'aretz Chutz La'aretz request somebody
in Israel who is not keeping Yom Tov
Sheni Yom Tov Sheni because somebody who lives
here doesn't keep Yom Tov Sheni Yom Tov
Sheni on Yom Tov Sheni Yom Tov Sheni,
can he request that do x, y, and
z for me? In other words, can you
drive over and pick something up for me,
can you do melacha melacha on my behalf?
It cannot be done by the person who
is keeping the Yom Tov Sheni Yom Tov
Sheni even in Israel, but can it be
done by somebody who lives in Israel in
Eretz Yisrael Eretz Yisrael on behalf of him?
This is going to be a three-part series
in order for us to see the whole
topic, so we're going to start today with
the fundamentals and then we are going to
see some additional critical points in the next
couple days. So the Sefer Yom Tov Sheni
Kehilchaso Sefer Yom Tov Sheni Kehilchaso tells us
that the majority of poskim hichriu haposkim hichriu
haposkim that the poskim poskim have decided that
when we have somebody from Chutz La'aretz Chutz
La'aretz who is in Eretz Yisrael Eretz Yisrael
and his da'as lasuv l'Chutz La'aretz da'as lasuv
l'Chutz La'aretz he is intending on returning to
Chutz La'aretz Chutz La'aretz on Yom Tov Sheni
assur lo lomar l'ben Eretz Yisrael sheya'aseh avuro
melacha Yom Tov Sheni assur lo lomar l'ben
Eretz Yisrael sheya'aseh avuro melacha. It is prohibited
from instructing somebody who is only keeping one
day of Yom Tov Yom Tov because he
lives in Eretz Yisrael Eretz Yisrael to do
on his behalf melacha melacha. That's very similar
concept that we have on Shabbos Shabbos for
everyone amira l'akum amira l'akum, we're not permitted
to instruct a non-Jew to do work for
us on Shabbos Shabbos when we ourselves cannot
do that same work. And in fact, in
our situation when it's Yom Tov Sheni Yom
Tov Sheni the Chacham Shlomo Chacham Shlomo points
out that this same situation, just like you
cannot tell a non-Jew to do work for
you that you yourself cannot do on Shabbos
Shabbos, you also a Jew who's keeping Yom
Tov Sheni Yom Tov Sheni cannot instruct another
Jew to do on his behalf work on
Yom Tov Sheni Yom Tov Sheni. In fact,
the Chacham Shlomo Chacham Shlomo says it's even
worse when you instruct a Jew to do
work on your behalf on Yom Tov Sheni
Yom Tov Sheni because there is a concept
of shlichus shlichus acting as your agent. A
non-Jew doesn't act as our agent when we
ask him to do work on our behalf
we're violating the issur derabanan issur derabanan of
amira l'akum amira l'akum, but here it's worse
because he's acting as your agent when you
tell a Jew to do work on your
behalf on Yom Tov Sheni Yom Tov Sheni,
he's acting as your agent effectively, you're doing
the work when he does the work on
your behalf. Just continuing, we said that hichriu
haposkim hichriu haposkim that that is the decision
of the poskim poskim, the vast majority of
poskim poskim are of that view, including the
Dover Meisharim Dover Meisharim, Rav Moshe Feinstein in
the Igros Moshe Igros Moshe, Dayan Weiss in
the Minchas Yitzchak Minchas Yitzchak, etc. There is
a Shlomo Zalman Auerbach in his Minchas Shlomo
Minchas Shlomo, he wavers a little bit on
this, he more is reconciling the minhag minhag
of those who are lenient on this and
he gives various rationales why people are lenient
in this regard that indeed on Yom Tov
Sheni Yom Tov Sheni they do instruct people
to act on their behalf and he brings
again different rationales for this, but lemayseh lemayseh
in the Yom Tov Sheni Kehilchaso Sefer Yom
Tov Sheni Kehilchaso he quotes Rav Shlomo Zalman
Auerbach as saying he didn't want to be
machmir machmir, he didn't want to say it's
prohibited to instruct a Jew to act on
your behalf because in fact there are certain
bases to be lenient, however even Rav Shlomo
Zalman Auerbach was choshesh choshesh for the opinion
of the osrim osrim of those who say
it is prohibited, so we do not have
a strong basis to be lenient in this
regard. Now to continue the prohibition, we said
that it's prohibited for somebody from Chutz La'aretz
Chutz La'aretz who's keeping Yom Tov Sheni Yom
Tov Sheni to request somebody to do work
on his behalf melacha melacha on his behalf
on Yom Tov Sheni Yom Tov Sheni that
applies ve'af lifnei Yom Tov ve'af lifnei Yom
Tov even if he instructs him before Yom
Tov Yom Tov begins, before the first day
of Yom Tov Yom Tov begins on the
second day of Yom Tov Yom Tov please
do x, y, and z for me, that's
prohibited as well. It's not only a prohibition
to give the instruction on Yom Tov Yom
Tov even if the instruction is given before
Yom Tov Yom Tov and is carried out
on Yom Tov Sheni Yom Tov Sheni that's
problematic ve'af b'remiza assur ve'af b'remiza assur even
hinting at it is prohibited. is also problematic.
Now in the footnote in the Yom Tov
Sheni Kehilchaso, he distinguishes between two types of
hinting and he says that he heard from
Rav Shlomo Zalman Auerbach sheberemez shehu derech tzivui
asur when you have a hint that is
more of an instruction to somebody, you're maybe
hinting but you're really telling him to do
something on your behalf for example to show
somebody with your hand to turn on the
light for you, that is instructing the person.
That is like Amira l'Akum on Shabbos, that
is Amira l'Yehudi, you're instructing him to do
something even though you're not saying it but
you're hinting it through your actions and you're
instructing through your actions, that is as if
you're authorizing requesting him to act as your
shliach and that is prohibited. However beremez she'eino
derech tzivui if it's a hint that is
not instructing and he gives an example kegon
lomar lo shehacheder chashuch vechadome like to say
it's pretty dark in this room. So you're
not instructing him, you're not indicating with your
finger to do an action but you're simply
hinting in a way that's not instructing at
all. It's dark in this room and that's
it and if he picks up on that
hint mutar that would be permitted because there
is no instruction there and if he acts
he's not carrying out your request, he's not
acting as your shliach. And then the Sefer
Yom Tov Sheni Kehilchaso continues another point vechen
rashai ben Eretz Yisrael lishol l'ben Chutz Laaretz
it is also permitted for somebody who is
not keeping Yom Tov Sheni because he lives
in Eretz Yisrael to request, to question the
person from out of Israel who's keeping Yom
Tov Sheni here while in Israel for Yom
Tov Sheni. He can ask him, would you
like me for example to light the light
for you or something along those lines veyachol
haBen Chutz Laaretz la'anos she'achen retzono bekach and
the person from Chutz Laaretz indeed can respond
yes please do so. Because here it's not
the person who's keeping Yom Tov Sheni, the
person from Chutz Laaretz that's initiating the request
but it's from the person who lives here
who's not keeping Yom Tov Sheni who's initiating
the request and in this he explains mishum
she'ein ze amira derech tzivui when the person
simply answers yes please, in other words yes
please turn on the light, yes please do
X, Y, and Z, he's not giving any
instruction he's simply revealing what his priority, what
his preference would be and accordingly this doesn't
violate the prohibition of requesting, instructing, or even
hinting an instruction to somebody if it's really
the person who is from Eretz Yisrael who
is initiating the action. So there we are
so far, we see there's a prohibition similar
to Amira l'Akum on Shabbos, we have Amira
l'Yehudi when it comes to Yom Tov Sheni,
the prohibition applies you can't even request it
before Yom Tov, it can't even be in
a remiza a hint that's of an instruction.
However what is permitted is a really vague
hint or if the person from Eretz Yisrael
asks if the person who's keeping Yom Tov
Sheni wants something done on his behalf. And
im yirtze Hashem starting tomorrow we will see
three exceptions that indeed we can be lenient
on this prohibition of Amira l'Yehudi, not instructing
somebody from Eretz Yisrael to do work on
behalf of somebody who's keeping Yom Tov Sheni.